-We have actually have children
who are very close in age.
I think your son is two months
older than my son.
-Oh, wow.
So your son's 14 months?
-Yeah, 14 months.
-Oh, okay.
-So congratulations.
You had not put any photos
of your son on social media,
but you just did.
-For over a year.
-Congratulations.
You made it longer than I did.
I had the plan not to.
-Yeah? And why did you?
-'Cause it was just, like,
the world needs to see
this little angel.
-This amazing gorgeous thing?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, mine -- It wasn't so much
that I was itching
for the world to see him.
I went to a restaurant
for Father's Day
with my son and my dad.
-Very sweet.
-And we --
It was by the ocean,
and my son was like,
"Awa! Awa! Awa! Awa!"
-Water.
-Yeah.
-And so I was like, okay,
you're going to get in the water
for the first time.
I slathered him with, like,
sun, you know, screen.
He was looking purple,
'cause he's black.
When we put on sunscreen,
we look purple.
And he just was looking crazy.
Got slammed by waves.
Sand everywhere.
We're leaving.
Paparazzi -- Chk-Chk-Chk-Chk!
And I'm trying to hide him
with a blanket, and I'm like --
I pull over to the gas station
after they get the shot.
I text his dad, and I'm like,
"I got to put this picture out
before the paparazzi.
I don't want them to make money
off of our child and
have the first picture."
-You wanted to beat 'em
to the punch. Yeah.
-So I post the damn picture.
Next day,
ain't no paparazzi pictures,
'cause Mama knew
how to hide that camera.
She's a supermodel for a reason!
And so now his picture
is out there,
and I didn't need it to be!
-You didn't need to do it.
But this --
You have a beautiful baby.
He's something else.
-Aww. Thank you.
[ Audience awws ]
-You know, I know that
you've sort of popularized
the idea of smizing,
smiling with your eyes.
It seems like that's what
your son is doing here.
-I know!
-Did he learn
how to smize from you?
-I am not a stage mom.
I don't want you to think
that I am saying,
"You ain't gonna get no peas and
carrots if you don't smize!"
No, he just has
that natural thing,
and I had it
when I was young, too.
But I do not
want him to model, Lord.
But he has that thing.
Look at him.
He's like, "Hello..."
-Yeah, no. It's very --
"I am smizing."
-It, like, pulls me in.
I'm like, "Whatever you want me
to do, I'm there."
Well, congratulations on him.
Congratulations on your show.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-So lovely to have you here.
Tyra Banks, everybody.
"America's Got Talent"
airs Tuesday nights
at 8:00 p.m. on NBC.